avec la crise sanitaire beaucoup de
projets ont dû être reportés voire
annulés par le château de versailles
spectacles depuis la réouverture le
château n'accueille que 500 personnes
par heure les grandes eaux musicales qui
devait débuter fin mars ont finalement
commencé trois mois après en juin
l'activité principale elle se fait aussi
beaucoup au moment de la reprise de la
haute saison
donc là on devrait pouvoir grosso modo
pour une dizaine de ses spectacles les
accueillir dans la saison qui arrive
donc on les a décalé dans le temps et ça
permettra de faire jouer les artistes
qui sont aujourd'hui beaucoup à la peine
est également de donner au public qui
bien les projets qu'ils avaient envie
d'entendre que ce soit en musique en
danse aux grands projets et puis
d'autres auraient été littéralement
reporté d'un an je pense au bal masqué
par exemple aux fêtes galantes ou à
versailles électro qui devait accueillir
18 mille personnes eh bien on les
attendra un an plus tard tout simplement
jour pour jour les secteurs du tourisme
de la culture ont grandement été touché
par la crise sanitaire les spectacles
reprendront lors de la saison 2000 20
2021 entre octobre et décembre et la
saison musicale quant à elle reprendra à
la fin de l'été à l'opéra royal non un
focus de chorégraphies au mois de
décembre parce que je crois que c'est un
mois où on aime bien sortir en famille
et bah c'était un projet la chorégraphie
qui peut s'adapter assez bien aux
enfants
il y aura une chorégraphie autour des
quatre saisons de vivaldi fait par
marie-geneviève massé
il y aura le spectacle de angelin
prejlocaj qui s'appelle voyage d'hiver
sur la musique de schubert ça tombe bien
ça sera en hiver où les danseurs on va
dire évolué avec un chanteur et un
pianiste qui chante les lieder de
schubert et le tout dans une atmosphère
allemande
on va dire de romantisme allemand assez
extraordinaire le même pré jo cage nous
donnera un spectacle s'appelle la
fresque qui est une création dia trois
ans et enfin nous finirons l'année comme
nous aurions dû la commencer par
définition avec l'anniversaire de
l'opéra royal les 250 ans puisque ce
sera avec le spectacle chorégraphique
marie antoinette qui raconte l'histoire
de marie antoinette à versailles pour
patienter avant la reprise des
spectacles et activités culturelles les
grandes eaux nocturnes feront leur
retour tous les samedis soirs à partir
du 27 juin jusqu'au mois de septembre